this class is on a world champions games
and basically we pick a game from won a
championship if you were here last
Thursday we talk about 1961 a world
championship where both Winnick defeated
Michael Powell week before that we
talked about
Petrosyan between NIC 1963 and today
we're going to talk about something that
happened only two years ago so not we
don't go back that much so this might be
fresh for some of you this game but it
still it was a very important game
basically after this game the match was
basically decided because Anand was
trailing by 2 at this moment and this is
game number 9 or the world championship
match played in India 2013 where Magnus
Carlsen won convincingly so he and at
this moment they were like only few more
games to go so Anand had to make a push
and he decided to play aggressively with
white and choose aggressive set up and
obtain somewhat a very promising
position when he had some good attack
attacking chances you will see but then
he just he just couldn't find the right
plan but Carlsen played fantastic and he
won this game and then he just wrapped
up the match after this so white player
is Vishy Anand the contender with oh
wait he was the champion actually at
that time and Carl Carlson was the one
who was challenging him I think yeah so
Knight f6 c4 e6
93 bishop before so which opening we
have now after black plays Bishop before
what is the name of this opening please
raise your hand if you know the answer
yes
yes yes this is the name so Indian
defense and now he played f3 right away
when the very aggressive system
he plays f3 trying to control the e4
square and immediately making the
position sharp I mean this is not the
best look and move on the board I mean
it takes away the square of the night
but he just wants to play the move efore
here very drastic way of trying to play
for a photo win here black has couple of
alternatives here
he can play c5 you can play d5 so but he
chose to play d5 just a common one now
white plays a tree attacking here and
earlier that year I think Nakamura play
the same thing against Carlsen and after
Bishop e7 before he obtained a winning
position against them he didn't manage
to win and in fact lost the game he was
completely beating and he was going to
be the first win against Carlsen in all
their matches but he didn't manage to do
it
so but Qasim was losing that game so he
didn't want to repeat that so he took
pawn takes and now I played c5 attacking
the center white has the pair of the
bishops which is considered to have an
advantage and now there's some
structural weaknesses here as well so
that's why you know black has that
advantage of that his structure is
healthy but white has that pair of the
bishops that is going to try to use
later on in the game so now he takes
Knight takes d5 is another possibility
here but it ate paan takes III and here
right away what plays a move that is a
little bit rare the following setup is
very natural for white here in common
Bishop d3 92 Castle very common way of
the
clapping the pieces so that's the common
way of playing it but black play the
move to prevent that because Bishop on
d3 is very active and the move is c4
pushing the pawn and locking the
position you got to be a little bit
careful doing that because if white
manages to break through with E for at
the right moment then he can push a 5
bishop can jump in on g5 as well so he
will have an advantage but black is
basically hoping that he can keep the e4
under control here so night e to natural
developing move knight c6
I play g-force like I mentioned to you
Anand was losing by two games and he had
to strike if he had any hopes here it
was you know he didn't have that many
white games left in a match so he had to
go for it so he didn't have time to just
try to grind down and you know and
probably he wouldn't be able to grind
down cost and he was playing excellent
chess so he actually had to do something
very aggressive and he opted for this
move g4 it's actually very interesting I
analyzed this position and it's playable
in fact you know it's very very
interesting I might actually play this
soon you know I had a game yesterday but
I didn't think about this if I thought
about it I probably played this way
because it's actually it's not so much
theory and black has to really play
precise here because if he doesn't play
precisely he's going to get on the heavy
attack very heavy attack could happen so
g4 castles Bishop g2 like I say why it
is planning to play e4 that's in his
plan so he wants to play E for at the
right moment now he goes Knight a5 the
knight on c6 is not very effective it's
attacking on d4 but cannot really go
anywhere so he's trying to go Knight a5
and to b3 to put some pressure on a c1
and a 1 so he's trying to to go to b3
and this is a what we call in chess a
weak square if opponent has a weak
square you want to try to put a piece -
so that's that's the idea castles knight
b3 rook a - if he puts the rook on b1
this is also playable move but he is
hoping to use the screw on the second
round look like a lateral ad you know
move the knight and perhaps move the
rook away and just have some attacking
ideas you can tell by the opening choice
that anon is going all out in this game
he is trying to
to win no matter what so carlson plays
b5 he has advantage on this side of the
board he has majority versus minority
here so he's trying to use his majority
93 a 5 g 5 this is a basically a very a
wild fight now because white is pushing
on the other side of the board Bach is
trying to get a contra play as soon as
possible on the other side of the board
now what can you do here as black white
just play the movie for opening up the
diagonal for his bishop what eating
blacks best response here is yes
well pawn wouldn't be freaking we'll
take it back and protect it yeah pawn is
not free but what do you think is it
still a good idea to take the bishop
what do you think which piece looks more
active than item b3 or the bishop on C
one night on b3 huh but two bishops is
two bishops right so we know that and
especially when there is a strong attack
coming up that dark square bishop could
be very powerful in the meantime your
night on b3 is a way away it's not going
to be any kind of defender that Knight
is just there doing his you know ideas
he it's not going to be a defender and
black has the Bishop f4 idea he would
like to go to so even though the knight
looks more active it's more important
for you to take this eliminate this
Bishop okay because this bishop would be
a good attacker here he takes back and
now rook a six he wants to have some
control in the sixth rank black is
crumped as you can see his pieces are
kind of defending here but they're
pushed back here and you're going to see
now white is going to gain even more
space now be five so we talked about
space advantage in a previous class look
you're going to see some real space
advantage here for Anand now he goes
ninety seven
F for white is trying to advance his
pawns playing very direct but here this
is a let it do be a smooth edge a nun
should have played another move here
first to prevent opponent's thread would
positional thread Knight c7 creates here
you still even though when you're trying
to push hard for a win you have to make
sure you still defend against opponent
threads so he's threatening to play b4
trying to make a breakthrough here
that's what it's trying to do right
so should play the move rook you should
have played a move rook to beat q
preventing that Queen d7 will attack the
pawn on a three now it just goes back
defending now rook b6 for example f4 now
takes
with this pin now Luke is pinned pick up
the pawn if nothing else advantage
advantage here for white so he was just
trying to go for it so he pushed right
away but this turn out to be a mistake
because that allow the strong
breakthrough now so he how should have
been a little bit more patient with Ruby
to here well you want to capture back
with a knight not the bishop because you
lose upon here yeah but it's you still
need you will need time to collect upon
so it's better it's playable yeah I
agree that this is playable but perhaps
I think it's better to have a knight in
to be able to take immediately now he
push broke break through he takes takes
take that good night so now if you
capture he can take back of the night
well an ant has one idea you know he's
just trying to do his attack Carlsen
push now he has a very advanced strong
protected passed pawn on b3 I mean if
you look at this position I think you
think white is just going to meet here I
mean he's just so advanced here but
position is very unclear here it's not
so clear actually White has a very
strong committing attack here
so he goes Queen f4 as you can see he
had ton of alternatives here you could
have played the move f6 he could have
played Knight h5 he could have played
even h4 h5 so there were ton of
alternatives here for him but he chose
this one Queen a4
now Carlson brings the defender in f6 g6
Queen h4 very direct play by Viswanathan
Anand he wants to go Queen h6 now 98 and
now Carlsen defended the best way he can
Queen h6 if it wasn't this pawn this
would have been just a matter of time
because now Anand has a winning plan if
let's say he can make another move here
he would go to cap for rue Kate Shore
and simply made on h7 and black cannot
really defend anymore because just the
rook lift comes in and it's over so he
push he is trying to create a passed
pawn rook f4
activating check
Knight f1 and now again here's just one
move away route comes here it's made
this night if one is a blunder double
question mark ish because he completely
overlooked blocks next respond block to
playing win who can find it who can find
a winning move for Magnus Carlsen yes
excellent and that is the move that is
going to force the resignation travel
Queen e1 Anand resigned and basically
after this game the fight for the title
it's over +34 Carlsen with three games
to go next game he just simply drew it
white and it was just done so here he
missed that when this move is played he
sacrifices him basically black will
start collecting material okay
instead you should have played a move
Bishop f1 and this move is only enough
for equality but now black to play can
you find the following very interesting
line okay it's a deep line here but can
you find it
it looks like rook is going to come to
h4 and still meet you but what are you
going to do here please raise your hand
if you know the move here very difficult
move but it's a good move for black you
have to be very resourceful in this
defense otherwise you will get mated
I think you're trying to say e4 Knight
takes e4 and then after rook h4 it's
going to be a problem
yes we knew one absolutely strong move
exclamation mark imagine you have to
sacrifice your queen back otherwise you
getting mated now how are you going to
take this huh rook or a knight look or a
knight what do you think correct so we
keep the rook in the attack right but it
looks like after this it's over looks
like it should be victory for black
because the bishop will sit prettily on
g6 stop all the threads and really it
looks like what you're going to do what
are you going to do here huh it looks
like black is just winning here no more
attack
he will go put the bishop on g6 put the
Queen on a5 again this is 2013 World
Championship game number nine crucial
game for Anand that he unfortunately
blundered it away with one mistake one
huge mistake he blundered the game away
here because it's still actually a draw
here if you find the right response here
it's going to be a close to a draw here
if you don't play this move you lose
okay Bishop g6
denne suggesting this response oh sorry
destroy your attacking ideas huh and now
the question is who is attacking who now
now who's king is getting maded now and
that is right okay good try good try
that was interesting try you absolutely
have to find this move here otherwise
it's just lost
what about g6 anybody thought about this
move sacrificing the pawn he has to take
it correct with the bishop it takes with
any of the pawns it gets made it so it
takes the bishop pin it and now look at
that threat you have you threaten h4 h5
again you still have a tremendous amount
of space advantage here your pawn
eight-six is very powerful and you just
radiate for h5 we need that bishop
so he took
I take
rook d5 you have to take the pawn back
Queen f3 now black is now on offense
again this is an analysis you go back
takes and this is roughly equal here
after all these complications we're
going to end up in this roughly equal
position okay black is actually black is
technically live tiny bit better but
it's going to be a draw all right
any questions yes we're going to go back
to the move one and review so if you
have a question glass you'll get to ask
then okay okay
take a good look at the final position
this didn't happen but this was how the
game could have developed okay and now
we get a review let's see if you're
going to remember the moves now okay
over review of the game d4 now start
next
is 6 right okay
next third move not sure okay
who knows it yes yeah for black
excellent
yes name of this opening huh
nimzo-indian defense who knows the name
of this line who knows the name of this
line here
huh can you you cannot see it I have it
here
oh it's Searcy that's the name cm ish
finish it is it has I feel like it has
another name I think this one but yeah
so this f3 very sharp okay just be for
next d5 now what do we do chase the
bishop ride takes takes two bishops
versus black did everything correct but
there are two bishops otech III
now what move did magnus carlsen play
here to surprise his opponent here
before very good s 90 to 96 castle
castle and now what did he play here you
remember correct and he played nine bTW
move to alpha is your question yes you
can yes yes but that's I can go Bishop
d7 now and then we should pay for yeah
stops your sacrifice because I'll pin
you and win a full rook okay without
pawn so Rho K 2 is better and then you
can swing it to diagonal so now look now
you have to do something to get a contra
place so you push nyeh 893 you continue
to push g5 98 a fold and here you
remember the key moment here he just
played efore what move you should play
now because he has a post
of threat okay what read that he does he
have now after this move he's not
reading to make you or anything but he
has a positional threat see who is going
to find it the positional threat white
just played efore any created a threat
not a winning threat but how why less
pieces opponent has less chances he has
to make you okay less pieces less mating
chances Tex Tex
Luke a six because he wants to protect
the rook with 97 and also you know
control some possible advances here and
now mistake by a non f4 rushing it
rushing it because he had an opportunity
to do what here rook p2 prevented
prevent before Queen d7 rupee 1 and now
play f4 it's good because the queen is
actually going to be under the temple
this queen is Miss plays here
go left 5 f6 okay
f4 before Tex Tex Tex takes f 5b v it
looks scary it looks like it's going to
be a checkmate here for block he's got
no defenders around his King white is
this three advance scary looking pants
with accommodation of the Knight Bishop
Queen rook I mean it looks like it's
going to be a maid here but somehow
black positions to very intact here no
weaknesses so you can't checkmate is a
so there are some alternatives here a
lot of alternatives here h4 this plan
will suggest it
again I wouldn't want to be black here
so if somebody hands to this position
say would you like to play I'm like I'm
going to pass on it you know I'm not
going to play in this position but yeah
as you can see here some some really
crazy lines it feels like white should
be winning here yeah like it just can't
play like this is computer moves and
just somehow
it says equal ish but no idea how is
this equal and anyway computer chess
okay I'm sure both layers with a blunder
couple of times in each side they will
do somebody with a one but yeah so here
97 6 T six Queen h4 98 Queen h6 b 2 r
okay 4 and now what was the move here he
played the blunder
because completely forgetting the Queen
e1 idea and after that he had no chance
to do anything he just simply resigned
and just lost it down a rock so he
should have played Bishop f1 Queen D 1
and now
correct
continue
it looks like again it's over now what
do you do
g6 now I wants to wage for h5 on peanut
right this position is too difficult to
play take take take and it's probably
going to be a draw but I think I like
but a little bit better say for King
okay right public individual so this
game should have ended a draw in a
perfect if both players to the plate
perfect then the game would have end in
a draw but the problem in chess it's
very difficult to play correct all the
time one of the players will make a
mistake okay we have a little bit more
time and now I have a very special study
for you that I prefer prepared for you
so let's see if you can solve this study
you are white here okay so let me flip
the board so you're white but strangely
not black has these two passed pawns
here and it looks like you're on the
verge of the last here why to play and
draw
difficult and difficult study the study
means it's a position that it was
composed by a composers study composers
and it's not an actual game but the team
is incredible
even the final position it's almost
unbelievable that it's going to be a
draw
it looks like Shirley Black is winning
so let's see if you can find it see one
night check
and you lose the game because of under
promotion see if I promote into a queen
you actually make me okay yeah I know
big problem
what to do here good calculation needed
ok good calculation here the good thing
about this studies if you don't see
anything and there are forcing moves you
got to start from that ok because a
group takes pawn as a good candidate but
then see one night wins that's out rook
takes rook King takes that's out because
my pawns Quinn so you can slowly do this
by even method of elimination here by
using that method
correct if you don't know what to do you
give a check remember check again if it
takes it then you take this guy it's
very important you take this guy okay
then you you make a draw so he's going
to go back then you're going to check
then he's going to go here this is the
tricky part
it looks like you're out of checks rook
takes a look
I take and acquaint
yeah but this the mangle King cannot
protect two pounds like that that's
never going to work
check deflected and you lose right here
you got to get creative okay
gotta get creative here rook takes a two
right now if he goes a queen then you
have Knight discovery check and you take
it's a draw
so it's still going to do this okay
check it looks like Inge and you lost
here we have to move away and he takes
your block on the promotion remember
that under promotion now if you take my
knight you lose your night but don't
give up yet 93 correct the knight is
trapped yes yes can I go to before and
c1 so a c3 cannot do much show but he
goes eh attacking your knight and ready
to go roopd - and protect his Knight and
win this game
King to see to attack the rook if you go
see you go back to a1 if it goes here
you take take take you catch these two
options to go to on g1 doesn't do any so
he goes here what do you do now if he
attacks you from here what do you have
for Kim excellent
if he goes the other way now you go here
if you attack your knight this way what
do we have work again absolutely fork
again okay excellent so on an open board
like this he's not going to be able to
protect this night stunning stunning
development here because most people
would just stop even calculating here
because it just looks like it's just
lost but yeah it's good position you
make a draw let's do this one more time
okay so you remember this so who wants
to start the first move and I check if I
go here you just repeat okay side revoke
in g2 next
yes
absolutely yes he has to get a knife
because if he gets a queen he of 93
check so he goes on the promotion check
on you where do you go very important
you play accurately correct and now
dominate the night do it excellent
excellent job now the night is trapped
okay
night is trapped cannot go here you take
it cannot go here you take it here you
take it as well
cannot do anything so it has to go here
you come over he goes here you come over
if you try to do this way for him this
way if you had gone this way you walk it
that way unbelievable position but
you're going to be able actually to get
a draw here and he cannot do anything so
studies I recommend you study okay study
more you know studies like this to
improve your imagination end games
calculations okay this is going to be
you know you will improve a lot from
doing and game studies